lo que se comentaba entre los ciudadanos
y turistas que intentaban refugiarse del
calor a la sombra de un árbol durante el
mes de abril en España lo ha confirmado
la agencia Estatal de meteorología el
cuarto mes de 2023 ha sido el abril más
cálido desde que hay registros en el
país Es decir desde
1961 la temperatura media del mes pasado
fue de 14,9 grados 3 por encima de lo
habitual para este mes primaveral en el
hemisferio norte las máximas fueron más
altas y las mínimas también subieron en
Córdoba al sur del país se llegaron a
registrar 38,8 grados Celsius este
fenómeno no es único de España Portugal
y Marruecos también superaron récords de
temperatura para abril Y es que según el
observatorio de la Unión Europea
copernicus el mes pasado fue el cuarto
abril más cálido a nivel global tan solo
0,2 grados por debajo del mismo mes de
2016 que es el que lidera esta
infamelista el mes pasado también entra
en el histórico como el abril más seco
desde hace más años en España en el país
llovió una quinta parte de lo habitual
una situación que comparte con el sur de
Los alpes y la región mediterránea de
Francia precisamente el ministro del
interior francés llega aldamana alertó
de que este año Será muy difícil en
cuanto a incendios forestales Y es que
Francia ha visto un déficit de lluvias
del 25% en invierno lo que hace que la
vegetación sea ahora más vulnerable a
las llamas de hecho Francia y España han
superado ya la media de incendios en lo
que va de 2023 y España y Portugal ya
cuentan con la mayor superficie quemada
de la Unión Europea de este año